hey everybody and welcome to a spey wesy
wild ride with steo I was excited about
this one because I knew this one was
coming out on the day that my bucket
list special is available worldwide and
if you're consuming this podcast on that
day then it premieres at 6:00 p.m.
Pacific 9 9 p.m. Eastern and anybody who
uh who buys it gets it for 30 days
fulltime watch it as much as you want
and man you're GNA want to because it is
insane I actually inundated Mr Chris
Deano with the first six minutes of my
special and the first six minutes has
Dick painting 2.0 like where the most
aggressive reimagination of dick
painting ever and let me tell you the
whole special is aggressive so enjoy
this podcast Chris Stefano is fantastic
he's a likable guy and man he's got
crazy crazy stories so enjoy this and
then get ready to enjoy the bucket list
unless he got to this late and you can
watch The Bucket List right now man what
an exciting time and let's get into it
hell yeah dude I like this that was this
was the best first six minutes of ever
meeting anyone yeah would you sick man
dude yeah painted dick balls um his toes
helicopters I like yeah I I I you know
what it is with specials like nowadays
because so many people have them that
you have to be so radically different
and I've never seen even an intro like
that let alone someone's painted dick
and balls in the first few minutes so I
think it's I think it's uh we got a hit
we got a hit on our hands you have to
yeah that is a hit yeah because I I I
would have easily count if you would
have said you're gonna have me on I
swear to God we're GNA watch this 60
Minutes it was it 60 minutes0 minutes
and then that was the show and I went I
would feel I would feel happy with that
I mean dude I would love to have kept
you and inundated you with the whole
thing um oh wow we got these Wild Ride
that's sick like you know I I I I would
I'm just like I'm I'm fiercely proud and
and um I I'll tell you in a second I'm
going to do our our our intro here okay
ladies and gentlemen Chris Toano hello
to stepy weffy to sty weffy I uh I like
it man I like uh this this is great I'm
happy I'm happy uh I'm happy to I'm
happy to see it man and I knew that you
were going to be like pretty good dick
siiz soft oh how about that good now now
what you're referring to I just sat you
down you walked into the van we met for
the first time first thing I told you is
I'm going to inundate you with the first
seven minutes of my new comedy special y
that is because I'm so confident that my
audience is going to love you that that
that that having you on the podcast is
such a win that I've I've blocked you to
come out when my special comes out W I
think actually the exact same that's hon
that's it I appreciate that's an honor
hopefully uh you know like the media
news finds some like old tweets of mine
and I'm even like you know like I'm
getting canceled as this is happening
and really exploded for you and and all
my demise and your eruption are you
gonna have a link I I love it I'm dude
November 14th is today as I understand
that is the release date you can go to
sto.com and watch the filthiest
multimedia presentation ever amazing
dude it looks good and you have great
teeth thanks bro yeah yeah if if you
were to get that like a rating would
that be an X it's full on pornography so
uh yeah you know that that thing I
described in the beginning yes oh it
happens really it happens I love it and
you'll see it on camera good oh yeah
good I like that I I think we need to be
thrilled you know like now like what am
what are you going to do like just watch
us tell jokes for 60 minutes and then
even the greats like Chappelle it's just
it's too
much you got to do something different
and with you the skyjacking I think is
something that people will follow in
your footsteps after that you're a
Pioneer right well thanks man thanks I I
I believe I don't think anybody's going
to do that ever I do you know I do I
think that it's a new thing and I don't
know man you might inspire me to go down
to Brea tonight and just
[__] dude I might give the front row
ponchos although I can't I haven't been
shooting ropes lately I think I have a
bit of a swollen prostate so I've just
been dribbling so I guess I'll just
shoot it off my sneakers you would know
that cuz you a doctor yeah well doctor
degree in physical physical uh therapy
physical therapy so um yeah that's my
education but I mean I'm I'm not even I
haven't practiced in 10 years but I did
get my license reinstated um during the
pandemic so I'm good dude I I heard you
say that you spent nine years uh in
medical training or medical school no no
no I I went to college and then four
years of graduate program and then a
year and a half of like a Residency
program okay so nine years of post high
school [__] oh yeah no I went to school
consistently from the time I was five
till 27 every single year I was in
school and you did The Residency where
you go in and actually yep yeah in New
York yeah um for pH for physical therapy
not like an actual doctor not like an ER
no no no no no physical therapy
massaging elbows I'm good at that what
made you choose that
profession I wanted to not ever work in
like a cubicle or anything like that I
didn't never want to be like a person in
like a sea of cubicles and my you know
my mom like never liked her job and I
would you know single mom I would hear
her hating her job all the time she like
I just sit in this cubicle I hate it you
know and I was like all right I don't
want want to do that so then I wanted to
work with kids so I became a pediatric
physical therapist and um and then I
started comedy in my first year of
physical therapy school so or last year
physical therapy school so I quickly you
know I was only a physical therapist for
like 2 three years but that initially
was I was like I want to cuz you know
you work with adults and then they
they're not grateful at all like you'll
you know like they just you know they
take for granted cuz we get like you
know we get older and we get we forget
like to have to be intive to things and
then but when you work with kids
especially disabled kids I mean dude
their families I mean all these kids
they're all in wheelchairs they have
cereal paly and this and that and just
to get them to like stand up or take a
step it's like a Monumental task and I'm
like that this feels better than you
know massaging someone's Pinky and then
them you know calling me a piece of [__]
cuz I messed one [__] thing up you
know yeah dude it's so interesting
because um the the one human who I've
known for the longest time my buddy
Abdullah known each other since we were
9 years old we graduated high school
together um I went on to do what I went
on to do but Abdullah went to Brown
University graduated with a 4.0 went on
to Cornell Medical School then became a
pediatric surgeon at the Mayo Clinic and
has since developed methods of uh
operating on unborn babies in the womb
and and and his whole rationality is the
same thing he does not want to work on
adults like he's almost disgusted by it
maybe I'm putting those words in his
mouth but I he's disgusted with adults
and only wants to help children because
they have innocence yeah he he was
saying that like he goes into the womb
he opens up you know all the the
amniotic sack and then does an operation
on the baby's fetus's spine fuses it
together sews the baby up and then sews
the sack back what look at all that look
at out all that genius all that smart
and and he's just known as sto's
friend Abdullah Abdullah Abdullah ABD we
should get him on the podcast he's he's
the best man he's absolutely the best
and I want to take a moment to be
serious and say that I think you're the
best dude like I I really like like we
we don't know each other did did we ever
do comedy like in the in the round
together during the pandemic no maybe
once or twice but never never spoke
right okay yeah yeah and um you know I
think what what uh I forget who who
reached out to who sooner but I think
you hit me up at dude I saw that clip of
uh you and Bert where you're so
emotional about how you know you
probably hear about it all the time but
I mean dude like it's just man I F fell
in love with you on that oh thanks yeah
that and that wasn't you know some
people like after that clip came out
they were like oh you staged that I was
like no I me and ber were having a great
time talking about just comedy and then
I don't know what the hell happened but
we started talking about our kids and
then I started to have like this
Epiphany live on his show about like how
much time I'm missing in my kids life to
pursue this and I'm like I don't want to
do that and you know right the way that
the clip played out you said you said to
Bert you know dude I'm killing it and
you know comedy's going so well I'm
touring I'm making tons of money but at
the cost of not seeing my kids grow up
you said that I'm watching my daughters
grow up through a
screen and you started to cry like it
was kind of a bad look for B If we're
honest because he's just sort of like
laughing at you like laughing at you not
even understanding like any importance
whatsoever for watching your children
grow up yeah yeah well then he goes he
goes you know I'm going to do that too
after that and then immediately like
within I swear to God like 24 hours of
that episode airing he announced a world
tour I mean and bird I love him to death
man I love him to death but it was just
so endearing and then when uh you and I
started communicating about doing each
other's podcasts you know we started
texting like you don't see that in this
day and age like people like responding
so quickly to a text message and writing
such like thoughtful fully formed
sentences right you know I'm like wow
dude this guy Chris is so thoughtful so
uh so kind and generous you know well
you know what I think that I think that
I with
comedy or some of my peers you know like
I came up with you know the mark
Norman's the Sam morals those guys those
was like my comedy class in New York and
those guys are true they know everything
about comedy comedy historians they know
it and they respect the art form and
it's beautiful thing to see where I just
came from I only started comedy for two
reasons the only things I ever wanted to
do was one make a sitcom show about my
dad and about the relationship I have
with my dad and second do comedy at
Madison Square Garden that's the only
things I that those are my only goals I
I didn't I was never like I got to be
the best and I'm going to I never cared
about all that stuff was always so like
Superfluous to me cuz I was like
Alexander the Great conquered the whole
world nobody gives a [__] like it's all
our own egos that create that create
this pump and Circumstance about
ourselves like none if it's real so I
was just like what do I want to do and
those are the only two things that I
wanted to do so for me when I like you
know like you was always such a fan of
yours I was like oh when you like I
you'll do we'll do this podcast and then
we'll turn around and do my podcast CU I
know it's a business I was like no dude
I just want to do you I want to I'll
give my energy for you I don't care if I
monetize it with [__] hellofresh who
gives a [__] it wasn't ju as a byproduct
of my gold chasing I get to meet cool
people and I'm like whether we monetize
that or not I I don't care it was very
generous of you to to say you know what
screw my podcast we'll just I'll give
all of my and all of my effort into
doing your episode and I I appreciate
that I also wish I could get on your
episode or on your podcast to promote my
special sure when you come to New York
or or I'll be I'm planning to be there
um the the week that the UFC is there
yeah do I do a podcast hey babe too with
s volcano from the practical jokers you
know him loves you guys it would be
great I feel like you'd kill on that I'm
going on their Cruise oh you are in
January so good it' be perfect yeah the
Eric Andre thing so yeah that would be
great like we hit it up knock yours out
when uh yeah yeah well have fun with it
what watch be a double upload anyway
because uh about the same time about the
same time who knows but yeah dude so uh
all kinds of exciting stuff um you're in
Brea I'm in Brea right now you were in
Brea a couple weeks ago I was in Irvine
a couple of weeks ago Brea this weekend
which was stupid my agent was like no
it'll be fine and I'm like it's stupid
they're too close to each other I should
just do one of them this year and then
come back in two years and do another
like no it's going to be great you're
going to sell them all out out and that
is not true it's not true I mean I'm
almost I mean you know how it here's the
thing too I had the great great thing
that happened to me is I had Lou CK come
on my podcast and he was in a bad mood
and that was good that was great as a
com not in a bad mood but he was just
being like he was in the mode of being
like let me tell you what the [__]
you're going to do and what your mindset
in this business is going to be and I
appreciated the [__] out of it because
it used to be if you don't sell out
right you think that there's some kind
of failure because of our business and
the Agents always want you to sell out
and they only make money if you make
money and this whole thing that's
happening and Louie was like listen if
there's 30 people in the room or 3,000
people in the room you play the games
that are on your schedule for the fans
that came to see you it doesn't matter
if you have 80% sold out or 100% sold
out the the money and all that it
becomes negligible at a certain point
just go out there and perform for the
people in front of you so now you know
like the manager will text me be like
hey sorry buddy this show uh the late
Show's not sold out and I'm like I don't
I I don't care anymore like I I'm not
embarrassed by it I'm like I don't care
it's like some markets you'll sell a lot
of tickets some markets you won't I
don't care I saw AR's Instagram Ari
shafir and he had this hilarious tour
schedule that's you know with the sold
out show added and then there was one
show next to it said selling
badly that's funny so [__]
great yeah is absolutely The Man He's
another guy he's another like very kind
of um Zen comic or like I don't know Zen
but like a person a good person to talk
to in this business because he's been
like cancelled he's been at the top he's
been at the bottom and he's kind of like
a good example of a guy who's like the
whole point of this is to just keep
going because like you know if you if in
one day you're like the king of the
world and then in 10 days that could
change and then the same token one day
you're at the bottom and in 10 days you
could be at the top so he was like the
the key is just stay in the presid and
keep going and I was like and he's good
because like he put out his special Jew
nam I know I could have named it better
myself and I would have put [__] in
front of it [__]
you sorry abdala um so so so I uh I I
thought like a themed special is the way
to go like what you're putting out it
has a theme it has a purpose I think
that's the way to go now and he he did a
great job of that even if I say so
myself I have to agree I did a really
good job you know what else I do a good
job at keeping my butthole totally clean
you know why because I wash it I don't
wipe it I wash it with my bedet from
Hello tushy.com and if you've been
listening to this podcast for even a
short time you've probably heard me say
that tushy is my favorite sponsor that
we've ever had because this product is
so important to me you know when you
take a dump and then just wipe it with
dry toilet paper like well you're just
smearing poop around like it's it's time
to start washing baby and stop wiping
wiping is for just drying off your
butthole once you've pressure cleaned it
to such absolute perfection that you
could eat off of it you probably should
have somebody eat off your butthole
because it's that clean man I love my
tushy bedet and if you go to Hello tushy
/o then you get 10% off your first order
and again this is my favorite product
I've ever promoted on this podcast and I
don't mind saying it I say it every time
hellotushy.com
sto to enjoy 10% off your first order
and man they've got different kinds of
bedday the the ace is insane so get on
over to hellotushy.com Divo and do it
um up until November 18th for the spend
and get special I don't even know what
that is but it's exciting hellotushy.com
Devo for the cleanest butthole you've
ever had now let's get back to it I mean
I've raved about you ever since I saw it
and then my bucket list special which
comes out today uh I got the same
director same production company same
Director of Photography as Ari yeah nice
that's awesome yeah I mean probably
because we have the same manager yeah
okay yeah it makes sense are you Jewish
too I'm Not Who okay I I I'm not but uh
I'm you know there's not many of us left
non-jews in comedy the Gentiles of
Comedy wow the only religious stance
that I feel strongly about is um that
I'm mad at the Christian concept of a
heaven which is exclusive to only people
that accept Jesus Christ as their savior
because that excludes my buddy Abdullah
exactly d and a bunch of other people
who I love Yeah and I've said loud and
clear man If Heaven's all it's cracked
up to be I'd love to check it out but
not without everybody I love getting in
and they're all faiths all types of
people yeah dude you know how many
babies would die in heaven if we can't
get abdulla in we need abdulla in there
dude to save those goddamn
kids are we going to get some Waterworks
over here you might dude you never know
it depends we need the clip yes we need
yeah oh we'll get it yeah yeah um but
yeah I mean I don't know I I just I'm
I'm uh kind of anti-terrorism pro love
same I think most right yeah we all are
dude I went out I went out it's so
comedy is so funny because like you know
it's nothing's funnier I think to other
comics when like a comic bombs so I go
out there last night and yesterday you
know this it is November 14th but last
night night was October 13th it's just
crazy the way time works but but last
night was October 13th which Hamas had
announced was World Jihad day wow they
announced yesterday was a big world
Jihad so I went out there and I said
guys listen first thing you know so
whatever it is four 500 people I said
listen I said I know today is World
Jihad day but let's make it instead of a
Jihad let's have a jaha bombed no laugh
bombed and then I said I'm sorry I'm
acting like a homosexual
and and it was
crickets all I heard was my guy who
works with me my friend Don deeta
[__] falling over on the couch in the
green room and and that is enough for me
I didn't care I was like at least the
comic left was he eating Hamas and P
yes yeah dude and [__] it but that
that's you know and then people like oh
that was too soon and I'm like shut up
no it's not where was this bre shame on
the people of Brea yes and and and I and
I say say that with a heavy heart
because BR has been very good to me oh
what a great Club it's a big room
there's a saying if if you build it they
will come and they did this remodel on
that club that is just out of this world
yeah I love that if I love Bria I love
and you're doing nothing with that
bitching ass LED wall behind you nothing
they ain't doing [__] no I'm yeah I'm
not I got to get more multimedia right
you're good you're good at that stuff
you're good at making it a show
sometimes with me I'm like what are
these people paying to see me talking
about stupid [__] I wrote my notebook I
got to make this a show man you put on a
show man you're painting your dick how
long will it take you to do a special
from this material um this is this
material that I'm working on I put on my
last special spey wesy um last year or
18 months ago and now I'm ready to go
with a new special um like within the
next two to three months I'll tap it
yeah w wow that's that's a fast well
because because what I try to do is um
when I'm have a special in the can when
spey wesy was shot I'd already had had
20 minutes of the new one you're always
going to be a little bit ahead so I I
try to do that so I got material now for
the next one stuff that I'm talking
about uh specific stuff with my
daughter's getting older that I'm I hold
back I do it like in the local comedy
clubs in New York but I won't do it on
the headlining set do you already have a
name for it for this special I think I'm
going to call it special little boy this
special maybe or because my last one my
daughter named spey wesy so I don't know
I don't know for me the name I don't
I've never been um so concerned with the
name or what the stage looks like I was
like oh it was always just about the
jokes now I think you have to be more
concerned with the name and the
algorithm and this but I used to like
when I would watch like Bill bur Lou CK
those are my two favorite Comics I never
I don't even know what the names of
their specials I just know the material
and and that's you know it's like go
their newest one or the last one yeah I
I'm like I know I know the bits I don't
know but again some people do some
people that's what they're all about
like music and I just never knew any I I
don't know what the hell I was do when I
was a kid or a teenager I don't maybe in
my own world but I never got I was like
I don't want to take time thinking of
this name so with the Netflix special
they were like coming up with all these
different names and all I was like uh I
don't know and then the very last day
when I had to name it I literally asked
my daughter she was six at the time I
was like what should I name my special
and she was like she had Nutella like
all over her hands and face she was like
spey wesy I was like that's it I mean
it's very on brand for you yes yeah
that's that's what it you know that
that's so I think I'll either call this
one special little boy I'll just maybe
I'll ask my 2-year-old my 2-year-old to
be three I'll ask I'll ask car I'll ask
car what to name I'll let the little one
name this one now in in the spey wesy
you uh had
a a joke about about somebody in Idaho
watching you said but if you're an Idaho
then like and subscribe and that kind of
threw me a curveball because I thought
hm was this uh taped for Netflix or was
it licensed after the fact like did you
expect that you were going to put it on
YouTube no no as a matter of fact they
when I filmed it nobody wanted uh you
know everybody was passing on me so I
said you know what let's just film it we
did it in the grammar City Theater in
New York Hometown I was like I'll get
you know my people there whatever I said
let's film it and I'm going to put it on
YouTube and I don't care and then at the
end of the special I said I'm putting
this thing on YouTube unless Netflix
wants it then I'll sell it to you right
I said that and in the middle in the
show I had multiple bits just like
[__] on Netflix because I got fired
from a show on Netflix for a joke so I
was like I'm just GNA whatever I this is
going on YouTube and then my agent sent
it to Netflix like you know the next
week and they turn around they're like
we want to buy it and I was like oh but
they were like you know we have notes
and I and I told you know my age tell
them I was like there's no notes either
they put it on exactly as I did it or
I'll just put it on YouTube like I it's
it's it's it the whole thing was for
YouTube so I'll put it on I don't want
any notes and they were like um well you
have to at least take the stuff out
about [__] on Netflix and I said
then I'm just going to put it on YouTube
like there's zero I will take out zero
just because I'd appreciative of Netflix
I'd be but I was like this whole thing
is you know my own fans for my fans I
only my career only started to get going
I started doing podcasts and and that
stuff I was like I don't the networks
never gave me anything I lost stuff from
them so I was like I was like I don't
care and they were like but respectfully
like not like I was like I respectfully
don't care I will not take a note from
you um and then they just like all right
fine well we'll put it on as is then
that's great it's a very it's a wildly
different experience than I've had with
Netflix right what are they why they I
don't like you know they they did say
that my bucket list special had just too
much dick in it and and
there and there's like there's the the
Seaman flying around yeah they're like
you know what we can't have sto's dick
on but we Canen put on the dictators
Playbook to teach people how to become
dictators the secrets of you know Kim
jnun and Osama been that's good but not
ste's painted [__] and and I don't know
man like I I I had a lot of like
self-consciousness around like you know
how people viewed me getting into
standup when I'm the jackass guy and
like that uh [__] kind of you know
bothered me for a long time it doesn't
bother me anymore you know it does it
doesn't bother me anymore like I'm
authentic in what I do I'm un
Unapologetic I don't give a [__] I go
out there and I do my thing and and uh
you know I'm good at it and you've been
doing it now for what 13 years exactly
so you got your 10,000 10 years 10,000
hours in yeah and and so um everybody
can suck my dick but the problem is that
that I think that Netflix and largely
the [__] you know people who put out
comedy specials they just still don't
they're not they're not opening up their
arms to embrace steo comedy welome let
them suck your paint fil dick yeah
that's exactly right and does Netflix
still have the negotiating power it once
had because PE and are they offering the
same amount of money they once were cuz
cuz people are like you did the
licensing deal yeah yeah cuz people are
like well I'll just go on YouTube and
make five million right with my own fans
that I've what do you mean go on YouTube
and make five million or like uh publish
it themselves or wherever they're going
to do it and make make the money well
they make the money I guess you know the
views and then they make the money from
the from the ticket payall yeah or a pay
wall like that's what you're doing right
I think yeah I mean I have to because
number one I can't put it on on uh
YouTube there's no way it's got way too
much dick sure and there's the seen
flying around and um also like dude with
the that opening sequence with the
helicopter and just all the different
things I filmed this thing was insanely
expensive I believe it yeah like and you
and that's all real you were really like
at any moment you fall off you're dead
um yeah like we we rigged we rigged me
onto the the rope ladder so to to
minimize the chance of me dying but uh
but the the the the falling from the
helicopter onto the roof of the moving
tour bus what there's no way around that
being [__] dangerous so you don't
want to die like in any of the stunts
you've done you're not you're not you're
not afraid to die you are afraid to die
you're just saying I'm going to conquer
my fear by trying to do this or what's
the thought process um my need for
attention outweighs my need for Comfort
or
um
life you'd rather you'd rather just have
people be like look at me like you want
I'm an attention wh through and through
I I I would go so far as just say I
think I'm a world class attention whr
right right well I mean but I think
because you know that and because it you
know that's why it's likable because
we're like well you know who you are
yeah well well thanks man you know like
I got myself tattooed on myself on my
back like it's bigger on my back than I
am right and uh you know that that's
just me kind of coming out and saying it
hey man like everybody's favorite thing
is themselves you love yourself I'm just
down with it you know good dude yeah
good man be who you are I respect the
[__] out of that well thanks man I
appreciate it and um I I'd like to just
um you know just loop back and and just
kind of take my own [__] on Netflix and
urge everybody listening or watching um
to support my bucket list special I
really want Netflix and everybody else
in the space to [__] regret rejecting
me regret looking down on me and I want
them to find out like how [__] good
my [__] is yeah dude I want this special
I want steo special to make serious
money like Ukrainian care package money
yeah that's what I want like I want Joe
Biden would be like damn I could have
given that to Ukraine yeah that's
exactly stuff like that right so um now
now what else you said you have three
kids I have three kids I have well I
have a stepson my 12-year-old stepson
and then I have an 8-year-old daughter
and a 2-year-old daughter okay but I
raise you know they're all with me
raising you know three kids yeah and and
and now you're in you're here in
Southern California performing at a like
I mean it's Comedy Club but the as big
as a [__] Comedy Club gets 570 seats
yeah 500 theater yeah 570 seats it's
epic that that's be basically like the
only kind of Comedy Club that you would
entertain right um no I I would do other
ones I'm doing other ones this month in
can in uh in uh in
because I I like good nights and good
nights yeah so I don't mind the some are
theaters but I like I kind of feel like
with the comedy clubs especially have a
practicing for a special I'd rather I
feel like those are really where you
practice the craft where the theaters
you have to like perform them more and
it's almost like sometimes you're doing
like a play where the comedy clubs is
like real like broken down like like
comedy like in the gym so I don't mind
um doing those weekends when the special
comes out after that it will only be the
the the theaters because you want to do
the one show and get home as quick as
possible but I'm in like practice mode
now so I do all these comedy clubs it's
like uh the baseball player who's on
Deck he's got the [__] the heavy
weighted ring around the bat because
it's like harder work so he'll switch
and in the comedy club it's kind of like
that weighted ring because you got to
fight through performing in a [__]
crowded restaurant with people
[__] dude the check spot you know
like the like I purposely like I always
try to take the last flight out possible
spend as much time at home as I can but
like I purposely yesterday I landed in
La at LAX at like 4:00 like 400 p.m.
flew across the country landed and then
you know traffic from LAX to BR it's
like we were walk it it took like 2 and
a half hours and like walking in the
show starting and then I had two shows
on New York time so it's like three
hours later in my head but I'm like if
you're going to practice then practice
with the hardest with all the weights on
you so it's like and if you can get
through that then it's like by the time
you film that actual special it'll be
like a walk in the park that that's my
mindset towards it making things harder
is one way to prepare but making things
easier is one way to make money
especially with ship station this is how
you make money once you've built an
audience online you sell stuff to them
and it's so much easier with ship
station because it brings into one easy
to use interface all of the different
shipping services and all of the
different selling platforms if you're
using Etsy Amazon eBay your own website
it all comes together along with the
United States Postal Service UPS FedEx
and they give you the best rates that
you can get rates that are normally
saved for like Fortune 500 companies
they make everything easier they make
everything cheaper and they make you
money man this is how we ship every
single item that we sell from sto.com it
is the secret sauce it is the secret to
Our Success you make an order Boom the
order the label gets printed out you
stick the product in the Box you put the
label on there and then boom off it goes
to your customer super easy you know
it's even easier if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo you get a completely free 60-day
trial risk free hasslefree free
trial and I mean dude you got to hurry
up and get on this while you can still
catch the holidays I mean man we are
slinging stuff for the holidays like our
steo hot sauce for your butthole you
think that's not the best stocking stuff
forever and how are we getting it to our
customers with ship station it's time to
make ship happen baby so go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo for your 60-day risk free hassle
free free trial yeah dude make ship
happen now let's get back to it did you
really drink six martinis before taping
spey wesy dude I was loaded absolutely
loaded I loaded like you can't imagine
and just forgot [__] like just went out
there and I was just like [__] it I had
an attitude at that time in my life
where I was like nobody wants this
so I don't care anyway it's all over I'm
going back to physical therapy so [__]
it so I just went out there SM I mean
smashed and um but I said [__] it you
know why the hell not that and then I
have the other thing in my career that
people know me from is is my 911 story I
went on if you Google Chris Stephano 911
story it's like the thing like people
will be like hey you're the 911 guy
which sounds weird I'm like no I wasn't
involved but they but they you know I
did this comedy bit back about 911 on
911 in New York City at the comedy
Celler and it's another thing I was like
nearly blackout drunk when I did it wow
like almost like I have little fuzzy
memories of it and I it was like the
only thing of my standup that like ever
went like truly viral and I was like
holy [__] I just put out 12 minutes and
I and I knew when I was doing that bit
like all the waiters and waitresses
stopped what they were doing and I saw
other Comics coming into the back of the
comedy Celler to watch and I was like oh
[__] what's happening right now and I
just kept going like telling the story
and then I was like I saw it the next
day and I was like dude I don't even
remember saying half of this [__] like I
was calling out like Vinnie guadino from
the Jersey Shore I don't know what I was
even talking about but I showed it to my
friend and he was like you have to put
this out immediately like this is what
you post and I was like nobody's going
to like this he was like just [__]
post it what was the gist of it so
basically on 911 I told this story about
how my mom worked in downtown in the
second uh building that was hit survived
was fine but I didn't know like where
she was like nobody knew where she was
and you know New York City was like kind
of wild on 9/11 and I um I didn't know
where they told us what happened and
then immediately I was like oh my mom's
dead and I started to cry and this guy
Frank this kid Frank started laughing at
me right and it's an all boy Catholic
High School very very strict high school
kid Frank starts to laugh at me and I
immediately just broke a chair over his
head like we were sitting in these
detached chairs and desks and I just
took the chair and I swung it over his
head and [__] like knocked him out
big thing and I got expelled from the
school on 911 I get home my mom is okay
you know like I I I I was like you know
she was we didn't know where she was but
I get home and she's there she's okay I
don't tell anybody anything and then I
go back into school we were off
Wednesday 911 happened on a Tuesday
Wednesday school's closed and then
Thursday I walked back in like I didn't
you know almost put somebody in a coma
and then this the teacher the principal
brother Rob was like hey D stepo what do
you think we forgot you're expelled and
I was like oh sorry you guys remember
that and they were like yeah Frank's in
the hospital I was like my bad and and
so I called my father and my father's
like you know kind of like um was in
prison when I was a kid um was like a
kind of In-N-Out you know great guy but
like you know like a a tough old school
New York guy from the Bronx like what
you see in the movies like that's the
type of guy my father was not so much
when he was Raising me but he has that
in him and you know it's probably what
my mother was attracted to when they had
me and and all that and so like a kind
of tough guy so I called my dad from pay
phone and I was like Hey Dad I got
expelled from the school and he goes
right away he goes here's the good news
no you didn't and I said no I'm I'm
telling you I did and he goes nope I'm
coming down there I'm going to negotiate
with this [__]
and so it wasn't like a thing like if I
had told my mother like I got expelled
or whatever it's what did you do oh my
God my dad cuz he's just been around
criminals and been around stuff he he
just he's calm he was just like you're
not getting don't worry about it he goes
I'm going to be there in 20 minutes I'm
going to talk to this guy now he lived
on Staten Island the school was in
Queens this was a Wednesday morning at
9:30 in the morning it's like an hour
with traffic he got there in like 15
minutes and I never forget he showed up
was wearing a New York Yankees uh
batting practice uh a New York Yankees
batting practice jacket and he had a
Dunkin Donuts coffee that was like a tri
XXL so this guy was like caffeined up
fired up and he walks in and we walk
he's where's the principal's office so I
show him we walk in and there's uh you
know in a um secretary there that you
know you need to make appointments he
walks right past her I never her name
was misset misset he walks right past
misset she goes excuse me uh sir you
need have an appointment he goes I I got
don't worry about it just do what you're
doing sweetheart I got one so he walks
in and I'm there and brother Rob is on
the phone so my dad goes hey can I talk
to you and then brother Rob says do you
have an appointment he goes Noah I don't
need one and he goes no you need one he
goes nah I don't need one he goes can I
talk to you and then brother Rob goes
I'm on the phone and then I'll never
forget my dad you know was like a like a
house phone he clicked the receiver on
the phone and he goes look at that now
you're not on the phone he like hung up
his phone call and then and then he goes
um he goes uh to brother um he's like um
so my son I heard that my son allegedly
hit somebody in the head with a chair
and then uh brother Rob goes well it's
not alleged we have he hits somebody in
the head with a chair there's Witnesses
he goes it's all alleged till he's
convicted and he goes brother Rob was
like it's not this is not a court you
know like he's expelled from the school
and then brother Rob was like um listen
he goes uh he's expelled and there's
nothing you can do it my dad's goes
there's got to be another way like he
just one of those doesn't take no for
kind of guy so my dad goes there's got
to be another way and then brother Rob
goes um there's sir there's no other way
like he's you know he could be arrested
for like what he did there's absolutely
no other way and then my dad takes out a
l of cash and he just put right in front
of me he just puts it on the table in
front of him goes there's got to be
another way and then brother Rob says
you're going to bribe a man of God and
then on that this is like it like got
etched in my brain he goes I lost God
September 21st 1979 and I'm like I don't
know what that date meant to him but I
know he was in prison and so I don't
even want to know what happened to him
that day but something definitely crazy
happened to him that day like I I will
never ask him but he was like that
September 21st 1979 I was like oh [__]
so then my dad goes let's figure out
another way and then brother Rob says
sir are you stupid there's no other way
and then my dad that's you don't want to
say that to a guy like that that's like
calling Michael J fox chicken yes
exactly and my dad goes um my dad goes
you just call me stupid and then he
looks at me he goes he just call me
stupid and I said yeah you know yes um
but I don't think he meant it like that
and then my dad goes yeah he goes
Chrissy when he call me like he would
that's what he would call me he would go
Chrissy lock the door so I was like what
he goes lock the door so I shut the door
and he goes and he sits down calm my
father he goes um to brother Obby goes
okay listen he goes now you have two
options he goes and he goes the second
option really sucks for you he goes
here's the first option just let my son
back in school he goes now here's the
second option and again this one's going
to suck for you he goes you're going to
think what I'm about to say is I've
heard it in a movie he's like I'm one of
the guys that they write these movies
about he goes I'm going to come over
there and I'm going to break both of
your kneecaps he goes I've done it
before I'll do it again he goes I will
call the police and I will give them my
name my social security number tell them
exactly what I'm doing and then I'm
going to still do it to you he goes I
don't care I'll go he goes I'd rather
this is another exact quote he goes I'd
rather go back to prison for the rest of
my life and be with my friends then you
throw him out and me have to listen to
his mother's [__] mouth for the rest
of my life he goes so the choice is
yours it's up to you and then brother
Rob like why does it goost cuz when you
get put in a position like that and you
know like there's this is like a
detached from reality man or at least
he's having temporary insanity type man
you you know like you're like I'm not
like in the movies you might be a tough
guy but in reality you're like I'll do
whatever you want me to do then and then
brother Rob's like okay well then he's
he's back in school he's immediately
he's immediately back in school and then
and then my dad says thank you he goes I
appreciate he goes now we got there
should be a penalty you know he's like
you know detention you know whatever
he's like you know yeah my dad's like
you know you don't get off scott free
with [__] like that but there should be
a penalty he goes how about detention
before and after school and uh we throw
and you know he can't be on the
basketball team or something like that
brother brother Rob goes that's fine
with me and I said Dad break his [__]
legs I'd rather not was that the first
time you've ever seen your father do
something like that that's first time I
ever saw my father act you know act like
that when I was younger I would see my
dad like the only other time I saw my
dad or I knew like oh there's something
like different about my dad as I
remember when I was maybe 9 or 10 years
old I would go with my dad's on the
weekends and my uh my mom
I was going like a Saturday morning he
was picking me up and my mom was like
you know Tony can you take him like
camping or something like he wants to do
the Boy Scouts but he's never been in
nature he's like scared of nature like
do something like hunting or something
with him can you do some type of
fatherson outdoor activity with him and
he was like uh yeah he goes all right
yeah I I guess and then um so but my
dad's not that guy either so like she
like my dad would take me to like OTB
like RAC trcks or like the aqueduct
horse track in New York City and be like
just tell your mother we went to the zoo
cuz he was like a compulsive Gambler and
so but like my that's why they got
divorced so he was like you can't tell
your mother that I gambled say we're at
[__] zoo but I would love it I mean
with my dad and his friends these guys
like these funny guys and I was a little
kid but he to took me we were driving in
uh New Jersey and um and he's like all
right we're going to go uh hunt and I
said okay and then he turns off the
highway not an exit just off the highway
like in the middle of an exit like into
woods and he pulls the car like a little
bit into the wood I thought maybe he was
going to go take a piss or whatever and
he goes we're going to go into the woods
and I said okay and he goes open that
glove box and I opened the glove box and
there was a handgun in there and he goes
uh take that gun he goes and I swear to
God I'm 10 years old he goes you've ever
handled the gun I was like no I'm I'm 10
and and and he was like it's easy I'll
show you how to do it and go in the
woods and so we go in the woods and then
he's like I you know deer or whatever
will be around he's like so I'll show
you how to do it first you see a deer an
animal like that you just shoot at it
doesn't matter if you hit it hunting's
about you just take a shot and so my dad
there's no animals there we're like in
New it's like kind of like urbanized New
Jersey and we were there for like 20 30
minutes and my dad was like listen
there's no animals coming he was like
I'll just take you to McDonald's just
telling your mother we went hunting I
was like okay and then that was you know
what I did I just told my mother that I
went we went hunting with my dad and it
was nice and he told me what to say to
her and that was kind of like my
childhood like tell telling my mom
things that I did that I didn't really
do that but but it's not like my dad was
like a bad guy for it was like we just
you know my dad was a great dad he was
just like he wanted me to have fun but
my mom's very conservative and my dad
was very like my dad so he couldn't tell
her like exactly how I was doing exactly
what we were doing so yeah but that that
911 thing that's um that was uh that was
like I you know told if you Google the
story it's like you know like a whole
full comedy bit but that was like the
gist of it to be fair the story was
minimally about 9/11 yeah almost is the
week of 911 yeah yeah yeah a great story
though I mean don't get me wrong like as
you told it I I I found myself being uh
like anxious be like oh man is this a
story that everybody already knows like
oh are we blowing it like was that like
a different version of it what do you
mean or was it like Verbatim what no no
on oh the bit the bit is like the bit is
like yeah it's it's it's been out there
it's more like you know stand up in I'm
throwing other things in the in the mix
of it but yeah is your dad still around
oh yeah did did you hear that bit oh
yeah he's heard it he still breaking
kneecaps yeah no he's he's he's cool
with everything cuz he's like you know
he's like yeah whatever you got to say
his whole thing is like with comedy is
like whatever you got to do just don't
use real names other than me you know
his my you know himself he's like any
[__] you saw at the my friends or
whatever like you know just don't use
real names and and then and then you're
good but I mean it was fun growing up
like in New York with guys like that
because like they were just you know
they're like funny guy like you know
like my dad had a friend Bobby pets who
he's dead and that you know I could use
his real name he was like a neighborhood
guy Bobby pets but he had like all
different like exotic animals and [__]
like you know like I grew up in a part
of New York that like is romanticized by
like movies and TV shows like
everybody's you know family is connected
to you know you know it's either like
was organ crime or the police or there's
always schemes going on and like you
know we all live on top of each other in
apartment building so it was like a fun
way to grow up and even when I started
comedy it was like I don't even really
have I mean I would write jokes but I
was like I was initially just like
writing observational material cuz I
thought like that's what you had to do
but I was like let me just start telling
stories about like things that actually
happened and I'll like you know
embellish facts here and there because
my own life growing up was like pretty
nuts like with these when you grow up in
New York you see Wild [__] yeah it seems
counterintuitive that you know with that
background that you became so like
highly educated and and and such a like
thoughtful like well spoken well because
my mom because because I think you only
get that way when there's like a reason
to like my mom was so adamant about me
not ending up like my dad or being like
my dad and his friends and she was like
your education like you will go to
school like Beyond school you have
like graduate school you will be in
school until you're 27 yes you will not
you will not ever you know you will
continuously go to school and you will
you know you will not speak like your
father you will not act like him you
will be different cuz my mom's Highly
Educated so she was like I this is not
happening so she was hellbent on those
things but then I got you know Street
stuff from my dad cuz my I know that it
was good sometimes divorce is good like
if my mom and dad were together they
would like would have not been happy and
I I would have not gotten it like just
time alone with my dad he would have
been like but like to be just like alone
with my dad and like have like one
parent where it's like school and you
know you will eat with the proper fork
and you will stay educated blah blah and
then to just have a [__] dirt bag on
the weekends was
awesome I I could see that it was it was
great and your dad's in New York New
York well now he lived in Flor he moved
to Florida now but he was in New York
you know my whole life um and then uh
and yeah he lives in in Tampa he lives
in Tampa now and um he's cool he's like
all my shows you know he's very support
he was the guy I always like respect my
dad because in the beginning with comedy
as I'm sure you know when you embarked
on jack ass stuff like nobody thinks
you're ever going to do anything with it
everybody the one thing like you know
sometimes I do college shows the kids
will ask me like oh any advice and like
my thing that I noticed about this type
of business is like the people who are
closest to you that love you the most
are the ones that will probably be the
least confident in you because they just
don't want anything bad to happen to you
so like your mom like my mom didn't mean
anything by it like she wasn't trying to
deter me she was like you just have an
education you have health insurance
you're making $50,000 a year like what
more do you want what more do I want I
want to be able to say
Mia you know what that means that means
my bucket list special is released today
baby and how did I say it I said that in
Spanish
and why because I wanted to and because
I learned Spanish I'm learning from
Babel this is how people learn
additional languages the fastest and the
easiest it's like playing a video game
on your phone it's fun you get the line
you figure it out you say it I mean dude
like 15 minutes a day and you could be
speaking a new language in as little as
3 weeks and 15 hours hours that's the
same as taking an entire semester long
University course in learning a new
language fast and easy with Babble
that's b a BB L babble.com
and if you go to babel.com steo you get
55% off come on that's got to be the
biggest discount that's ever been gifted
to the listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast 55 % off your subscription if
you go to babel.com
Devo and it doesn't get much more ESP
special than that so babel.com Divo and
let's get back to
it and you know and and she's like don't
do not go for your dreams like that's
too dangerous but like my dad was more
like hey you [__] go for it now he
was like who gives a [__] he was like
what do you want to be on your deathbed
and be like all I ever did was physical
therapy he was like you're going to feel
like a [__] loser he was like you
should go for comedy and go for it now
he's like and you live in my basement
until you make it you just [__] live
here and he goes it'll be my our little
secret you don't have to tell your
mother tell you're still a physical
therapist but just [__] quit he was
like quit tomorrow he was like [__] that
even like even like when I got my oldest
daughter when I met her mom we she she
got pregnant on the first date so like
the mother of my children I'm still with
today like I met like literally the
first date impregnated with my
8-year-old so my mom very conservative
Irish Catholic woman you know obviously
if I got a girl pregnant she doesn't you
know out of wedlock whatever this is a
big problem for my mom so I could only
tell my dad my mom told my my girl told
me that she's pregnant and you know and
we're going to keep it and and all that
and I was like great like I'm in you
know whatever and then so I I had to
call my dad and I was like Dad like you
know I [__] up you know like you know
all that stuff and he goes oh hold no
wait a second wait a second he goes no
no no no no you did not [__] up okay he
goes we're going to bring a baby into
this family you did not [__] up he goes
how do you know that that baby in there
is not going to be the next short stop
for the [__] New York Yanke he goes
that's who it could be he goes that
that's how he thinks he goes that could
be for the [__] Yankees think about
what you do to steinber a family getting
rid of that baby so I'm like okay so he
goes so he goes he goes we what what
what are you going to tell your mother
and I said I honestly don't know like
can you help me and he was like here's
what you do you ready for this I said
yeah he goes he goes here's what we're
going to do he goes you know your
[__] mother she is not going to like
this he goes so he goes here's what I
want you to do I want you my girl's name
is Jasmine he goes I want you in
introduce your mother to Jasmine right
now he goes how far long is she he goes
about about 6 to8 I said about 6 to 8
weeks he goes you checked I said what do
you how would I [__] check check what
are you talking about he goes I don't
know I just the doctor [__] checked
the baby's there at 68 weeks I said yeah
I think so he goes all right he goes
here's what you do so she's not showing
yet I said no he goes here's what you do
you introduce her right now today to
your mother this is my girlfriend the
love of my life ma this is the one right
here bang he goes and you get you you
don't say a [__] word about that baby
he goes cuz what you got to do is you
got to get your mother and Jasmine
together they got to be friends your
mother's got to fall in love with this
girl he goes you got to basically
impregnate your mother with the idea of
your girlfriend being impregnated he
goes so get her [__] pregnant with
Jasmine mentally then this time in 3
months bang we have a baby it's not
going to be so bad she's going to be
like well you know what I already love
Jasmine this is a blessing if you tell
her now you're [__] and I did that and
the day I told my mom she was like I'm
so disappointed you guys didn't tell me
earlier what a beautiful celebration of
life so my dad was like you there you go
he goes there so he he had he he's good
like Street advice like that man I want
to get your dad on the podcast dude he
like I'll never forget like he's still
to this day like makes me think I
actually heard them say it in Cobra Kai
the show Cobra Kai and it made me think
like my dad used to say that to me I
remember like when I would be going
leaving his house some sometimes on the
weekends on like a Sunday night and
sleep at his house and then go to school
from his house on a Monday morning and
he uh I remember when I would leave
sometimes occasionally he' like Chrissy
never forget what I tell you boiled
water okay it hardens an egg but it
softens a potato are you the potato or
the Egg have a good
dad that's best you know and I Bean like
yeah you do a documentary about your dad
I know well the thing is he's like you
know even him like you know we do comedy
whatever like bit you know you know you
make him large in the life a little bit
but the younger version of it like he's
you know more subdued now he's 75 he's
but when I was a teenage
that's how he was like he was that guy
that was just like you know he would
just say [__] you know quotes he always
had quotes he always had [__] to say he
always had like things that you could
you know figure out smart things you
know like and then he would get you know
like kind of like dark stuff too like if
you want to know how to be successful in
life look at me look at your father do
everything exactly opposite of what you
see in this man and then you'll be
somebody he was like don't you don't
want to be like me be the opposite of me
I would be like it's it was a weird
thing to hear cuz I was like I love this
guy like everybody loves this guy but he
was like you do not want to be me and I
was like oh wow was that you talking on
a podcast about like uh you saw your mom
crying your dad was pissed off at you
for not doing anything the guy who made
her cry when you were like 10 so my mom
yeah she dated this guy and then he um
he my parents got divorced when I was
like one and um and and my dad got
remarried great w a wonderful stepmom
and um and and so and so he uh but you
know he always like cared for my mom cuz
you know they shared a child together so
he was always more like you know we got
this is the mother my child she has my
protection and my love forever because
even though we didn't work out
romantically we I I'm going to support
her in other ways and so my mom was
dating a guy I was like 10 or 11 my mom
was dating a guy and um and she um I'm
sorry I was like 15 156 and my my mom's
dating this guy and they had a good
relationship and then he dumped her out
of the blue and started dating a woman
who lived directly across the street
like directly across the street so my
mom was heartbroken and one day I came
back from school or whatever and and she
was crying like she had pulled up a
chair in front of the window we lived on
the second floor to the apartment
building she was looking out the window
like waiting to see if this guy who just
broke her heart was like walking into
his like new girlfriend's house and she
was like crying and upset and I was
teenager I didn't know you know I just
went to [__] jerk off so I didn't
know what to do so I just went in my
room and started playing like video Gam
games I didn't pay any attention to I
didn't know how to deal with that so
like my dad was coming over to take me
to baseball practice and I was in the
room playing video games he comes and he
sees my mom crying he goes you all right
to her and she was like yeah I'm fine
fine I just you know I'm fine and he was
like okay and then he goes where's
Christopher and then she was like he's
in his room playing video games so I
hear my dad like you know sh coming in
with 250b [__] gorilla I hear him
coming in he goes hey stupid he was like
what the [__] are you doing I was like
uh I'm playing video games he was like
your mother's out there crying I said
yeah he goes you know what it's about I
was like that guy you know that guy John
he was she was Da and he goes yeah I
know that [__] [__] and I that's he
said like he just hated all my
boyfriends he goes he goes I go yeah he
goes well he dumped her and he's dating
a woman who lives across the street and
my dad goes are you going to do
something about
that and I go what do you want me to do
about it he goes I'm going to be right
back do not come outside and and I said
okay so I was like I'm going to wait 10
seconds and then immediately go outside
and my daddy goes I'm getting us bagel
and he's like who wants bagels and then
I was like nobody but okay so he goes
goes outside say a minute or two go by
play my video games and I hear my mother
screaming Tony stop stop it right now
you're going to kill him stop it and
then I run downstairs my dad had rang
the bell waited for this guy to come
downstairs dragged him out Stein and
started beating the out of him like like
Roda good fell it was like you know not
with a gun or anything but like like a
full fist fight and then I run
downstairs and my dad's by that time
walking back across the street he goes
that was your job to me I was like what
what and then he goes uh he goes you
going to let your mother cry like that
you're not going to do anything I was
like what well like I I remember I
literally remember being 15 16 years old
that day being like I had a psoriasis
outbreak all over my arms and I was so
itchy I was like what do you want me to
do and he was like uh he was like it was
your job and then you know the thing
with my dad is he would always do
something like that but then also be
like okay I went too far cuz then we
were driving back to Staten Island and
we're sitting in traffic on the verzano
bridge and he goes um like out of
nowhere he turns on the radio it goes
you know that was wrong what I did back
there right I said yeah I know Mom knows
the police know like everybody knows
that that was wrong like they're thank
God they're not pressing charges on you
like we know that that was wrong goes
well all right he goes but you know the
lesson I'm just trying to instead of
[__] playing video games like an
[__] go Comfort your mother she needs
you he's like you know I'm not here
anymore I'm not here every day you're
the man of the house right now so just
go be nice to your mother and I was like
okay my his way for compensating your
shortcomings yes the only time my dad
hit me once and once in my life only I
was it was actually around that time I
can't remember if it was before or after
but I was like let's say 15 16 and a you
know argument with my mom whatever
teenage [__] and I called her my mom
a [__] oh boy yeah and so like you know
like I don't even know the context I
said I really don't even remember
because of the concussion my father's
going to give me I'll tell you about in
a second um but he I called her a [__]
and then my she told my dad right like
hey this kid like you know he's getting
out of line now whatever so my dad comes
to the house one day and he comes
outside and he goes uh he goes come on
he goes let's go to uh we'll go to the
bar we'll get a beer and said um like I
swear you're like 15 yeah 15 he goes
we'll get a beer which he had never done
that before like he wasn't even a
drinker like he had never said that and
I I was like what do you mean we'll get
a beer he goes well go come get a beer
with me he goes you're a man now and I
said no I'm not I'm 16 and he was like
no you're a man you called your mother
woman a [__] that's what men do right
and I said no what do you mean he goes
come get a beer with me if you're a
you're a man you're calling women a
[__] you can't have a beer you're
scared to drink a beer but you call your
mother a [__] I don't get it and I was
like um and then I I start getting
really nervous cuz I know he's like he's
like this is this is not going to be fun
outing right now he does not want to get
a Beery yeah he's like come on he's like
he's like it's like a game that he's
playing he goes but I thought you were
he goes I I could have sworn your mother
called me and told me you you're my son
right you I go yeah he goes called me
you you called her a [__] right he goes
am I [__] crazy didn't you call her a
[__] and I said yeah but I didn't mean
it he goes I thought I so you did I go
yeah he goes I know and then bang punch
punched me like full like in my chin I
don't know that he followed through but
punched me that I like fell back into
the wall and then immediately gives me
like a big like bear hug like at first
it was like a squeeze like to like keep
like the pain but then it like became
like a fatherly like like loving hug and
he was like whispering in my ear was
like I'm sorry I love you I love you so
much I had to do that don't ever make me
do that again but if you ever call your
mother a [__] again I'm going to hit
you every single time and and then he
goes so go up there and apologize to her
and we'll go get pizza and then I went
up there apologized and then you know
she said you know my mom was like what
happened cuz I already knew by this cuz
my dad had talked to me many many times
about do not ever be a rat that was do
not ever be a rat if I in kindergart
like I knew that already like I knew
that from the from the horse track stuff
with the horses and tell her we're at
the zoo there was one time we went to
Yankee Stadium and like we were really
really late and he made me not you know
I to tell I couldn't tell my mom that we
why we were at the game so late I had to
rat make up this I couldn't be a rat I
had to make up this whole story so I
knew what was going on so my mom like
noticed like a big thing on my chin she
like what happened to you I was like I
fell down the on the stairs outside she
you know cuz I at that time I had a
bicycle I was like I I tried to carry my
bike down the stairs and I fell down the
stairs and she was like oh you got to be
careful honey I said yeah my dad's here
is gonna go get pizza she's like okay
good and I said I was want to say I'm so
sorry for saying what I said she's like
I know honey I know she's like I told
your father and he was going to talk
have a talk with you about it that's
what today is about he's just going to
have a talk with you at the Pizzeria and
it's going to be fine but I know you
didn't mean it and I'm like yeah well I
[__] can't see straight because my
dad I'm like I'm probably going to the
emergency room tonight I have a [__]
concussion but that's just how he was
that's epic that's epic dude yeah and uh
how much of that is going to um be
instilled in your kids
so that's the thing is I say about my
father I always say he had like the
right intention but the wrong move and I
feel like with nowadays especially
having daughters yeah like I don't know
even with my advice from my father it's
like tough because he's like I don't
know what to tell you how to raise a
daughter I have no [__] idea he was
like a son I you know just [__] couple
of swings you just and they're like they
start to listen he's like you cannot you
cannot hit a girl you know so he doesn't
you know I don't know it it's tough you
know my my daughter's their mom is
Puerto Rican and very like strong like
you know Latina strong minded so I don't
really worry
about my daughters especially my older
one as much CU they're very you know
strong-minded but but I I I'm not like
him I'm not like my dad I think I have
bits of him in me but I would never do
the the things like I wouldn't I you
can't raise your kids that way way well
right but say for example like the 9/11
story you know like are you going to
like go and tell people like I'm ready
to break your legs because you did
something wrong to my daughter see it's
interesting no but my their mom will so
there I remember being my again fiery
Latino Puerto Rican girl beautiful you
know you know like just like like what
again stereotypical Latina just hot
Spanish girl tattoo on the tit like real
deal just [__]
like you know and like just a mom like
you know Puerto Rican woman like a mom
like will [__] kill you for her
children my oldest daughter she cuz my
my girl Jasmine's more like my dad's
side right she has like that hot streak
so my so my oldest daughter is you know
let's call it 6 months right maybe a
little older maybe eight months we're in
the elevator in our apartment building
where we're living and we're coming down
and she had a pacifier in her mouth it
was just me Jasmine and and my baby and
um a woman gets in a very like Professor
like you know we were living in part of
Brooklyn Park Slope if you guys don't
know Park Slope it's like very
gentrified and you know like everybody's
like woke and you know like f what
whatever that's where we living it was a
nice neighborhood good for families and
so this woman gets on and she's like
looking at the baby right and I could
feel Jasmine being like don't look at my
[__] baby right I could just feel it
and I'm like holy [__] and we were on
the 11th floor and I'm like this
elevator cannot get to the lobby quick
enough like I I I and I and I'm like
just like just get down and so she's
looking at the baby and then looking at
us and like it judgment like a judgy
look and I was like you know like just
like smiling trying to be nice I like Hi
how are you and then Jasmine's just like
staring like at her like and you know
and then finally this woman says she
goes how old's the baby how old is your
child and I was like oh she's 6 months
have a great day it's you know she's
beautiful child we love her so much 6
months and then she goes hm she goes
isn't she a little old for a
pacifier and then I swear to God I see
Jasmine close her eyes and I've never
seen this before and I didn't even know
like that this worked she pressed
Jasmine pulled the emergency stop on the
elevator with me my baby and Jasmine and
this woman on the elevator and she goes
what the [__] did you just say to me and
my baby and she goes and the woman goes
um I'm just saying it's a little old for
a pacifier just saying that she's a
little old to have a pacifier and she
goes why don't you mine your [__]
business before I put a pacifier in your
mouth [__] and I was like oh my God and
I was like guys guys guys I was like
stop stop stop I was like there's no
reason to fight right now let's just get
to the lobby everything's fine and then
the woman was like the woman was like
you need to handle your woman to to me
and then ja and I was like it's it's
okay like I was like I was like it's
okay no problem I was like everything's
fine and then Jasmine turns to me she
goes why are you talking to this [__]
and I was she was like you got you
[__] like this woman I was like no
I'm just trying to get us to the lobby
and so everybody and then we get to the
lobby and the thing is if you pull that
one of those emergency exits emergency
breaks I'm sure it's the same in any
City but like the fire department
immediately gets called like there's no
they just get a call Direct to the like
that is a 911 emergency so we get down
to the lobby and the fire trucks are
pulling in and so we're walking out and
then the fireman he goes uh what is
everybody okay and I said yeah I said
well you know um there was like an
emergency exit poll and they who pulled
the exit button and I said uh you know
again not being a rat I said and then
Jasmine popped up she goes I did and she
goes why he goes why did you pull the
emergency exit he goes and she said the
woman was like kind of walking a little
bit ahead she goes because this [__]
right here told me that my daughter is
too old to have a pacifier and the FDNY
is like a old school New York Guy this
is like you know gentrification you have
like people not from New York living
with people from New York but the FDNY
those are all old school New Yorkers and
the guy goes uh he goes you know it's a
$500 ticket for just you know pulling
that and calling us you know without in
real emergency and she was like well
what do you want you know I'm sorry and
then he goes nah he goes [__] it he goes
I [__] hate these people the fire
department he goes I [__] hate these
[__] people they need to mind their
[__] business right I said yeah he
goes no ticket [__] it have a good day
he goes I should give her the ticket for
being a [__] and I was like yeah I was
like you should and then I remember that
leaving that day and Jasmine you know
just being like um just mad at me for
the rest of the day because I talked to
to like another
woman um that's great that that story
eerily reminds me of times when my girl
has mouthed off in ways that just
straight put both of us in danger yep
like don't do that you know there's
nothing good to come out of mouth and
off at somebody you just just shut up
you know like because because women
think because
women they think that men like like then
I have to like defend your honor but I'm
I it's nice to be in a relationship with
someone like my woman's not expecting
that of me like I can't I'm not the guy
that even like knows how to like build
anything or do anything so like you know
she's the one that like puts up
sheetrock and [__] like that
so yeah how many times has that happened
with you I've only heard once in New
Orleans I haven't New Orleans was a
major one you almost gone to like a
brawl it was it was it was like a pretty
scary looking Street person and like I
forget what the what it was but it was
like you know maybe like walked by and
brush should shoulders she's like you
going to apologize or what or something
like that and it's just like and and the
guy turn around he's like huh she's like
yeah yeah what yeah what now or
something and she's and the guy says her
he says you talking like that is
dangerous for your man
for sure and I'm like yeah you know I
mean I don't even know if I remember
that right I just that the gist of it
and and there there's just been like a
couple other ones but she's she's down
to fight like she's probably been in a
couple fights in her life I'm sure it's
just counterproductive you know like
there's certain times when engaging with
confrontation has zero upside and
significant downside potential yeah like
I I noticed like there was a couple of
times where like a girl would like
comment on like a a post or something on
Instagram and I remember I saw once like
girl commented like like just hearts or
something like that and then Jasmine
commented right below try it [__]
that's what she wrote like in
public yeah I mean that's kind of cool
though it's kind of cool you know like
you know like or if she thinks if
anything at all like you know she's just
that's the thing it's like at times it's
like you know you think like being with
a jealous woman is like but it's like
it's kind of like fun it makes you feel
this girl will [__] kill somebody and
it sounds like to an extent like you get
to be the good cop and she does the bad
cop that's that's convenient it's
convenient yeah I mean you know like the
kids are not scared of me at all they
are scared of her that's good yeah have
you been able to find that balance since
you had that that breakdown on Bert's
podcast have you been able to find that
balance between family life and work
easy it was not a breakdown it was he
was emoting in a healthy way for sure
yes have you been able to find that like
a healthier balance yes he's got his
kids with them on tour is that right uh
they've come on some well now that
they're in actual they're in school so
not this time but I had these dates that
I'm doing now through the end of the
year were already on the schedule but
the news you know S A after that there
was already like planned but you know if
you notice like on my schedule like
February 2nd and third are the last
dates Nashville and DC and then I'm you
know from that all of 2024 the plan is
to do maybe one weekend a month or you
know just take time off and just like be
in New York because um you know it's uh
you don't want to I actually had Andrew
Dice Clay on my podcast and he's amazing
to talk to because if like you know he's
got like this unshakable confidence like
he is just like all like dice he's like
you know I knew he said straight up on
my PO he was like I always knew that I
was going to be Andrew Dice Clay and he
said the same Andrew D he said you know
Andrew Dice Clay sold out the garden and
then 10 years later was doing like
bananas comedy club in Hasbro Heights
New Jersey inside a holiday and express
off the side of the highway he's like
when I looked in the mirror I saw the
same Andrew Dice Clay both times I never
I just [__] do it and so you think
like he's just about him right and
that's what you would think with dice
but then he started talking about his
kids and he was like I took 10 years in
my career away from Comedy cuz I just
wanted to raise my kids he goes and even
when I went back on tour I made Monday
Tuesday Wednesday our weekends and I
would take them bowling and I would take
them to Apple bees and do stuff that
normal dads do with their kids on the
weekends I know I had to work so I made
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday really
count he was like so that's what you
should do rather than taking all this
time off he was like just make it count
when you're there with your kids and
you'll be all right and they'll be happy
and you'll be happy so I was like okay
I'm going to do that sweet yeah so Dice
Man you ever meet Dice Clay or no Dice
Clay I I have like uh with um Tom Green
is a good buddy of mine and he and dice
are are super close dud he dice is is is
so [__] as soon as he walks in like
you know it's 2023 like you got to be
careful with how you talk to people and
like as soon as he walked in like one of
the girls who works on my shows like you
know very attractive girl in her 30s he
goes oh look at her he goes this is 1989
I'd be putting it right in a pig
pie she'd be bent over getting in the
pig pie oh good
like great and then you know but it's
like somebody says that to you like even
her you know she's like 30 years old
like you know woke kind of girl she was
like laughing she's like this is like
crazy you're like my
Dad wow and um how did uh that that
episode perform with dice dice I haven't
it hasn't come out yet okay gotcha we
come out I think it'll come out next
week but I've gotten to the point now
too where I used to be heavy on like how
does is this going to do the even guess
the algorith I don't not that I don't
care because this is a business and you
you know it's careers but I'm like I'd
rather just dedicate an hour to two
hours of my life to talk to people that
I just want to talk to whether it's
going to help the show or not right you
know like I think we're all starting to
feel that like we're all like the
podcasting it's becoming like like Colin
Quinn is like a mentor of mine and he's
been in the game 35 years and he's like
you know the difference between your
generation and his My Generation Colin
generation is like it's like you know we
had one Outlet standup comedy and we
would only do it once a night or on the
weekends he goes you guys are talking
for hours and hours and hours and hours
and hours being funny every week between
your Instagram and your podcast and
whatever else you're doing goes and then
by the time you do standup it's like
you've said everything you've purged
everything you're exhausted he was like
you guys I'm telling you it's like one
one of the two is going to give out the
podcasting or the standup you can't keep
that up it's not it's not going to work
and I was like that's interesting cuz I
think a lot of us that I'm talking to
are starting to feel that with
podcasting and I'm like the way that it
works for me now is rather than just
talking to someone for a business thing
I'm like I just want to talk to them CU
I want to talk to them and do the
passion you know I I I like that a lot I
I'm still gripped with fear by the idea
that any podcast won't perform I get it
no listen I get it I get it and it's
like it hurts when you know things don't
do well or you don't sell but at the in
at the end of the day sometimes I'm like
well what does it all matter right if
you can just kind of pull out out the
perspective be less micro more macro and
think hey it's not a Sprint it's a
marathon you know big like just keep
chugging along yeah just keep doing it
and then you know just keep uh you know
you got to be careful too cuz I think
sometimes when things are really good
like I heard this quote once from
makavelli not Tupac the real makavelli I
heard a quote he said um men desire
novelty so much that people who are
doing good wish for a change as much as
people who are doing badly and I was
like oh [__] that's a good one cuz it's
like sometimes you have everything and
you're like I want to switch it up but
it's really just because you're like you
want to change and now you could [__]
your whole [__] up you know got to be
careful yeah it's like the Talking Heads
quote uh never for money always for love
yes yeah Oprah I remember I was I had
Mono and my mom had gout in her foot and
it was like eighth grade and we were all
banged up I was Dad punched you for
having yeah I had [__] mono and like
all this [__] and my mom's toe she was
like King Henry the 8 and we were um
watching TV and I saw Oprah um was on
maybe it was Dr Phil she was on but I
heard her say and I don't know why it
got like etched in my mind she said the
money always comes second the passion
first the money second and if you follow
that rule you'll always be okay and I
was like oh it's true I I think that
that really checks out man like like you
were talking about you know going for
your dreams and the people who love you
the most are the ones that will really
not support you and and following your
dreams and that that resonates so much
with me because when I was dropping out
of the University of Miami in
1993 and telling everybody it's going to
be great I'm GNA videotape crazy [__]
with the home video camera and I'm going
to become a famous stunt man yeah like
everybody legitimately felt sorry for me
right like it was just tragic interview
like what a tragedy what's a good great
thing about you that I even struggle
with I don't have this you knew from an
early age exactly what you wanted to do
and exactly what you wanted to be you
had a very
clearcut see it seems at least from the
outside looking in like I know exactly
the vision of what I want because it's a
niche thing to say I want to be the
great stuntman it's like not many people
are you know everybody wants to be a
[__] athlete or a general comedian or
an actor but you're like no no I want
specifically that and you took it to the
top but you did not have that as a kid
like you did not know that you wanted to
be a comedian no I did not I'm I still
don't know that I want to be comedian
I'm doing I'm doing this because I had
those two specific goals to write a
sitcom about my father and to perform at
Madison Square Garden and you got
Madison Square Gardens theater I did the
theater at Madison Square Garden not the
arena I'm going 5,000 seats yeah and I
did R well the good news I had done
Radio City the night before so it was
5,000 seats Friday 5,000 seats Saturday
so when you get 10,000 cumulatively now
you're kind of like knocking at the door
of the real Garden so I haven't gotten
any info on it yet but I know my agent
like pushing so if I could get that goal
um and then my if I got those two goals
I I don't know I don't know like where
my mind would go if that happened what I
would either have to try to come up with
new goals or maybe Feel Complete I I I
don't know yeah I don't know I I uh was
sitcom that didn't get picked up was
that about your father yeah that that I
illegally put that on my YouTube at
Christy comedy uh.com or youtube.com/
Christ comedy you can see that I've
illegally put my unaired CBS pilot up
there put it 3 years ago in the middle
of the pandemic they were like oh this
will be a $5 million lawsuit they've
never said anything so it's just up
there watch it um Chaz Pomer played my
father um you know from A Bronx Tale and
um and it was awesome but you know I
want to try it again that that didn't
get on the air but I learned that was a
good Learning lesson because that was a
year of my life making that pilot for
CBS where like you know they're
introducing you to like Ray Romano and
Kevin James and you think you're going
to be the next guy and and then it gets
all all doesn't work and I was like oh
at first I was like oh that's a bummer I
failed but then I was like oh no it was
about like the journey like all life is
like that's what it's about the journey
like I was like look at all these people
I met look at these opportunity I had it
was never really about making the show
it was like about just getting the
opportunity to go along on the Journey
of at all um and then if I wouldn't have
if I would have got that sitcom I would
have never started podcasting so I can't
say that it was like a full failure like
it sucked in the moment that I didn't
get it but then I was like oh it
motivated me to be like well I got a
little kid my daughter was like a year
old at the time I was like I got to
[__] make money for her so I got on
that podcast I am uh compelled to watch
that pilot on your YouTube Chan it's a
real [__] hole it's a real [__] it
really sucks I mean khakis I mean that
was the first thing Colin Quint said he
goes the [__] are you doing with this
show I was like what do you mean he goes
why are you in khakis I was like because
they said that that's what people in
Iowa wanted to see is is people in
khakis and yellow and blue sweatshirts
because they think it makes him think of
the University of Michigan and that's
the audience he was like you're stupid
on the exact quote Colin coin we were
standing on West four Street he goes
you're a stupid [__] and then he took a
bite of a Sicilian pizza and walked away
from
me yeah well I I uh I still I still want
to watch it yeah uh
youtube.com Christ D comedy that's where
all my stuff is at podcast everything's
there the the unired Google CBS unaired
pilot it's there at the bottom somewhere
and it's it's good it's uh well it's
it's it's so bad it's good there you go
yeah Nat Yes Yes W watch that [__] and
and people get on sto.com to support my
bucket list do it do it [__] do it
this guy dropped out of University of
Miami for you yeah do it that's right
and dude like uh I appreciate you man I
meant everything I said that that uh you
know like a thoughtful guy a considerate
guy generous guy like uh and and I
really like the way you text yes sir
I'll continue to text you and now now
that I've seen your paint the dick
you're going to I'm fired up dude I love
it man love it man thank you guys thank
you bro appreciate it man there we go
man can that guy tell a story or what
and I I I meant every word I said about
him thoughtful
articulate responsive she a good guy a
good guy who I'm rooting for and man I'm
rooting for you too I'm rooting for you
to have a blast watching The Bucket List
tonight sto's bucket list and if you're
watching this or listening to this like
a day after it came out good news you
can watch The Bucket List right now oh
so exciting so exciting so watch it let
me know what you thought I know you're
going to think it's the craziest thing
ever because it is it's the craziest
[__] I've ever done and um man tell your
friends about how [__] crazy and
awesome it was too it's a big day for me
today thank you for being here I love
you